[Musique]
était ce soit dans les enjeux si vous
avez un adorable c'est vrai il a essayé
quelque chose avec vous pas spécialement
avec tout le monde
non mais oh non
quand il est parti qu'est ce que vous
avez dit de midi tous ouais stallone qui
arrive au début on a été très content
parce que ben voilà cinq chroniqueurs
emblématique et on était vraiment ravi
de l'avoir et de montrer que maintenant
les anges on peut être sérieux qu'on a
de vrai projet professionnel et non il a
été adorable nous associer c'est un
boucan vraiment c'était une journée
riche en rires en fait si guillaume
hoarau
mais oui nous a fait rire un peu obsédé
sur les bords alors qu'ici les chais
aussi si l'échec parce que je vois à la
télé d'habitude c'est très classe et
chic is et gs utilisé